hi everyone its Johanna here this is a
full six weeks weight training plan to
help you burn fat and to link up instead
of the traditional strength training
this workout plan is based on super
cells super sectioning are designed to
increase your heart rate increase your
metabolic rate and to turn the muscles
by decreasing the rest time between sets
one super cell has two exercises perform
10 repetitions per exercise do the two
exercises listed together with no rest
time in between and repeat the superset
for a total of 3 runs once they've
completed the first of all set move on
to the next superset with no more than
one minute rest in between
super sets short rest time will result
in greater calories burn and greater
after burn do this weight training plan
for six weeks to reduce your body fat
and to lean up so what you'll need is a
pair of dumbbells if you can choose two
pairs at two different weights one
lighter pair at two to four kilos each
and one medium weight at five to seven
kilos each this workout will only take
approximately 30 minutes to complete so
here are the exercises for Monday and
Thursday the muscles to focus on our
legs back and triceps superset one
dumbbell front squat and jumping lunges
dumbbell front squat stand shoulder
width apart with your toes pointed
forward gently rest a pair of dumbbells
just above your shoulders keep your body
upright and get your core and lower your
body as far as you can by pushing your
hips back and bending your knees then
drive with your heels back up to the
starting position and repeat tip your
knees should not go over your toes so
push your hips back jumping lunges stand
shoulder-width apart
and lunge forward with one foot jump
straight
as you throws your arms forward keeping
your elbows bent switch legs in mid-air
and learn in a lunge with the opposite
leg forward
super set to dumbbell plank row and
dumbbell row start in a push-up position
keeping your core tight balance your
weight on one arm as you pull the
dumbbell in the opposite hand up to the
side of your chest with your elbow
closed and pointer back squeeze your
back muscles lower the dumbbell and
repeat on the opposite side for
beginners you can start on your knees
tip keep your body straight by engaging
your core throughout the workout
dumbbell row keep your body upright
lower your upper body by bending from
your hips until it's nearly parallel to
the floor without moving your upper body
row the weights upward close to your
chest and squeeze your shoulder blades
together lower the dumbbells and repeat
superset three tricep dips and tricep
extension tricep dips place your palms
on the table chair or stepper with your
fingers pointed forward keep your legs
straight and body close to the chair
lower your body towards the floor by
bending your elbows hole for two counts
extend your arms raising your body
upwards and repeat for beginners you can
choose to bend your knees for an easier
option tricep extension hold one
dumbbell with both hands and lift it
over your head until both arms are fully
extended the palms of your hands should
be facing up toward the ceiling lower
the dumbbell as far as you can and
extend both arms straight up towards the
ceiling and repeat tip your upper arms
should remain stationary close to your
head throughout the workout and only the
forearms should move
super set for dumbbell deadlifts and
swimmer back extension dumbbell
deadlifts stand shoulder width apart
keep your body upright and dumbbells
close to your body slowly lower the
dumbbells past your knees by thrusting
your hips back and bend your knees drive
upwards through your heels pulling your
shoulders back and hips slightly forward
tip keep your head up and chest open
throughout the workout swim a back
extension lie on your belly face down
legs straight and arms extend it out in
front exhale as you lift your upper body
and legs off the floor pull for five
counts and squeeze your back muscles by
bringing your elbows close to the side
of your body inhale release and repeat
for Tuesday and Friday the muscles to
focus on our chest shoulders and biceps
superset one chest press and fly chest
press
lie on your back knees Bend and feet on
the floor bend your arms and keep the
dumbbells in line with your chest exhale
as you press the dumbbells toward the
ceiling squeezing your chest muscles and
keeping the elbows slightly bent inhale
lower the dumbbells to the starting
position and repeat fly lie on your back
knees bent and feet on the floor
keep both dumbbells together in line
with your chest with palms facing each
other as you inhale slowly extend your
elbows out to the side in a white arc
until your elbows touch the floor but
don't rest them exhale and return your
arms to the starting position by
squeezing your chest muscles superset to
show the press and up right row show the
press hold a pair of dumbbells with your
palms facing forward elbows banded and
the dumbbells in line with your ears
keeping your body upright throughout
press the dumbbells over your head lower
and
be careful not to arch your back by
engaging your core throughout the
exercise up right row stand
shoulder-width apart hold the dumbbells
with your palms facing the body use the
side of your shoulders to lift the
weights the dumbbells should be close to
your body as you move it up close to
your chin and your elbows should always
be higher than your forearms lower the
dumbbells back down and repeat superset
three bicep curls and arm circles bicep
curls stand shoulder width apart hold
the dumbbells with your palms facing
forward exhale curl both arms up
bringing your palms toward your biceps
inhale and uncurl back to the starting
position tip keep your elbows close to
your side throughout your upper arms
should remain stationary with only the
forearms moving arm circles extend both
arms out to your side palms facing up
keeping your elbows slightly bent make
10 small circles with your arms forward
and 10 small circles in the opposite
direction keep your arms extended to the
side and avoid dropping your arms down
superset for spider-man push-ups and
plank up down spider-man push-ups get
into a push-up position palms in line
with your chest slightly wider than
shoulder width apart as you lower your
body bring your left knee to your elbow
at the same time repeat on the other
side beginner start with push-ups on
your knees plank up down get into a
plank position by supporting your body
on your elbows and toes feet close
together arms 90 degrees with your
elbows directly under your shoulders
exhale and fully extend both arms into a
push-up position lower yourself back
down and repeat tip aim to keep your
body straight throughout with minimum
hate movement here are some additional
fitness tips breathing technique exhale
when you live the waves and inhale when
release always focus on proper form so
keep your body upright throughout the
workout by engaging your core muscles no
slouching do not rush the moves remember
nice and controlled movements not jerky
moves this workout is Peto proof as it
gets easier increase the weights use
increase the repetitions to 12 reps per
exercise increase to 4 rounds per
superset and decrease the rest time
between super sets if you stick by this
workout plan for the next six weeks eat
clean and perform twenty to thirty
minutes of cardio at the end of each
session I can assure you you will
produce your body fat and Lena all the
best for new fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to my youtube channel and
website do you follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter to stay connected
with me thanks guys
you